and a local woman is looking for her  hero tonight jennifer boxley was in a  crash back on july 20th near the 2 15  and the i-15 interchange she says she  and her diabetic autistic child were  trapped inside the car until a good  samaritan ran out on the freeway came to  the rescue but before she could say  thank you he was gone  when our car was spinning  on the freeway  people were honking at me like i could  stop  and so  it was very nice to see that  somebody wasn't so cutthroat here  you know and they actually cared just  want to tell them thank you  that he doesn't even know that he really  saved a child from  potentially  getting really hurt  jennifer says her hero was possibly  asian wearing what she says looked like  a yellow work vest she and her son are  doing well in a rental car while theirs  is getting repaired but still they'd  like to find that hero and say thank you